we're starting to see Rises of
depression in this generation we're
starting to see Rise of suicide in this
generation we're starting to see a rise
of accidental death due to drug overdose
from this generation now those are all
extreme examples the less extreme and
more likely example is that someone will
go through life just never really
finding Joy or fulfillment and
everything's just fine how's your job
that's fine how are your friends you
know they're fine because Joy
fulfillment comes from this it comes
from human interaction we are social
animals and we need it we have age
restrictions on alcohol we have age
restrictions on smoking and we have age
restrictions on gambling we have no age
restrictions on this other
dopamine-producing device called social
media or cell phones it's the equivalent
of throwing open the liquor cabinet and
telling our young adolescents I know
this is a stressful time try the Vodka
it'll get you through these hard times